اذاعه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
هذا صنعان السميري وحاليا جاهز ان شاء
الله بالوصول للنهايه
قدرت اني حلقه الميداليه الذهبيه في
الحواجز واحطم الرقم السعودي والرقم
العربي في هذا المسابقه
[موسيقى]
بالفن تسرب الى اعماق الشعبي الكبير
لالعاب القوى يدخل منافسه في مجموعه من
اللاعبين اللي انا فعلا كنت تفوز عليهم
واستطاعوا انهم يتوجوا ميداليات في
اولمبياد
يراودهن عن نفسك كان في طريق حياتي انفجرت
قنبله
اجتماعيه
كان يريد ان يتيح فرصه للدماء الجديده
الزمالك الزمالك
على طول يعني كان فيها انتظار الى انها
تظهر النتيجه في الساعه في وقتها كنا يعني
في حير
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
اثناء القاء القصيده كان الصمت عم القاعه
واخترت ان اكون من اظهر كما انا انت
مفصوله عشان انت طلعتي بالتلفزيون
اكيد مثل الفريق هلا بيدك شيء
لعبه فعلا تدريبها ممل قاسي
يعني العمل
[موسيقى]